>>> THE JANUARY 6th SELECT
COMMITTEE HAS OBTAINED MORE THAN
TWO DOZEN TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER CHIEF
OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS AND GINNI
THOMAS, THE WIFE OF SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS,
INCLUDING THIS ONE SENT AFTER
THE JANUARY 6th ATTACK.
IT READS, WE'RE LIVING THROUGH
WHAT FEELS LIKE THE END OF
AMERICA.
MOST OF US ARE DISGUSTED WITH
THE VP AND IN LISTENING MODE TO
SEE WHERE TO FIGHT WITH OUR
TEAMS.
THOSE WHO ATTACK THE CAPITOL ARE
NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR GREAT
TEAMS OF PATRIOTS FOR DJT.
AMAZING TIMES.
THE END OF LIBERTY.
JOINING ME NOW IS CNN CHIEF
LEGAL ANALYST JEFFREY TOOBIN.
PUT THIS INTO CONTEXT FOR US,
JEFF, INCLUDING THE FACT THAT,
REMEMBER, IN JANUARY, JUSTICE
THOMAS WAS THE ONLY ONE WHO
DISSENTED IN THAT DECISION TO
ALLOW THE COMMITTEE TO RECEIVE
DOCUMENTS FROM THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE FROM THE ARCHIVE.
>> WHAT IS IMPORTANT ABOUT THE
MESSAGES IS NOT THE REALLY
EXTREME AND SOMEWHAT CRAZY VIEWS
THAT GINNI THOMAS EXPRESSES
LIKE, YOU KNOW, THAT BIDEN AND
HIS SUPPORTERS SHOULD BE SENT TO
PRISON IN GUANTANAMO.
IT IS REALLY, REALLY EXTREME
STUFF.
BUT SHE'S A PRIVATE CITIZEN,
SHE'S ENTITLED TO HER VIEWS.
WHAT IS EXTRAORDINARY IS THAT
HER HUSBAND, JUSTICE THOMAS,
REMAINS SITTING ON THE BENCH, IN
CASES DIRECTLY RELEVANT TO WHAT
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT, IN THESE
TEXTS.
HE, AS YOU POINTED OUT, HAS
ALREADY VOTED ONCE IN DEFENSE --
THE ONLY JUSTICE IN DEFENSE OF
THE TRUMP POSITION ABOUT ACCESS
TO MEMOS ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
THERE ARE MORE CASES IN THE
PIPELINE ON THIS SUBJECT.
AND HE HAS CONTINUED THROUGHOUT
HIS CAREER NEVER TO RECUSE
HIMSELF IN CASES IN WHICH HIS
WIFE HAS BEEN INTIMATELY
INVOLVED AS A POLITICAL FIGURE.
>> AND, TRUMP, I MEAN, WE'LL
RECALL LOOKING BACK ON IT,
JEFFREY, THAT TRUMP BELIEVED THE
SUPREME COURT WOULD COME THROUGH
FOR HIM BECAUSE HE HAD APPOINTED
SO MANY JUSTICES IN PART, BUT HE
WOULD TALK ABOUT MY COURT.
HE EXPECTED SOME ALLEGIANCE.
HOW DOES THAT FIT INTO ALL OF
THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, THE THING THAT IS
SO EXTRAORDINARY ABOUT THIS IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE --
THE -- GINNI AND CLARENCE THOMAS
TALKED ABOUT THAT THEY ARE A
TEAM.
NOW, THEY ALSO SAY THAT THEY DO
NOT INTERFERE WITH EACH OTHER'S
WORK, BUT, YOU KNOW, THE
TRADITION IN COURTS HAS BEEN
THAT IF A JUDGE'S SPOUSE IS AT
ALL INVOLVED IN A MATTER THAT
COMES BEFORE THE COURT, THE
JUDGE RECUSES HIMSELF.
NOW, WHAT IS UNUSUAL ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT IS
THAT THEY HAVE EXEMPTED
THEMSELVES FROM ALL THE ETHICAL
RULES THAT OTHER FEDERAL JUDGES
ARE ABIDED BY.
THE SUPREME COURT OPERATES
ENTIRELY ON AN HONOR SYSTEM.
THERE IS NO FORMAL RULE FOR WHEN
JUDGES SHOULD RECUSE THEMSELVES,
BUT, YOU KNOW, BY ANY REASONABLE
STANDARD, CLARENCE THOMAS SHOULD
NOT BE SITTING IN ALL THESE
CASES.
>> WE SEE IN SOME OF THE OTHER
TEXTS, SHE'S REFERENCING HER
COMMUNICATIONS WITH OTHER
PEOPLE, BESIDES MARK MEADOWS.
JARED, SHE SAYS, SHE TALKS ABOUT
SYDNEY POWELL.
I WONDER, AS TRUMP WAS HOPING
THAT THE SUPREME COURT WOULD GO
HIS WAY, DO YOU THINK GINNI
THOMAS' COMMUNICATIONS WERE
GIVING ANY INDICATION TO THE
FOLKS, INCLUDING MARK MEADOWS,
THAT, YEAH, MAYBE THEY WILL?
>> YOU CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT THE
TRUMP PEOPLE KNEW THAT GINNI
THOMAS WAS CLARENCE THOMAS'
WIFE, AND SHE WAS GIVEN SPECIAL
ACCESS AND SPECIAL OPPORTUNITIES
TO MEET WITH THE PRESIDENT
THROUGHOUT THE PRESIDENT -- THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TERM.
THAT DOES SEEM TO BE AN EFFORT
TO APPEAL TO HER HUSBAND.
AND IT WORKED IN ONE CASE.
HE WAS THE ONLY JUSTICE WHO
VOTED FOR TRUMP IN THE FIRST
JANUARY 6th CASE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WENT ON BEHIND
THE SCENES, BUT THIS IS
PRECISELY THE REASON WHY JUDGES
ARE SUPPOSED TO RECUSE
THEMSELVES WHEN THERE IS T